good evening and welcome tonight what
you did not hear about during the
testimony a former Special Counsel
Robert bowler before Congress the facts
of how the Russians targeted
african-american voters in an effort to
keep them from going to the polls a
strategy that almost exactly paralleled
that of the Trump campaign during the
last election political pros call it
voter suppression so how was it that a
group of Russians in an office building
in st. Petersburg were able to precisely
target the same voters that Republicans
were targeting here just a coincidence
the misinformation effort on the part of
Russian trolls this morning we're
learning Russian interference went
beyond the election the Russian set up
30 Facebook pages targeting African
Americans there's been all this talk
from the malla report to the Senate and
House investigatory committees about the
fact of Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election what there hasn't
been is an examination on how they
sought to interfere in our elections
Marc Morial a former mayor of New
Orleans
now runs the National Urban League it
appears as though a big part of their
effort was designed to suppress African
American voter turnout she was followed
by for example creating trolls and memes
and fake personalities who were
associated in a line with the black
lives matter movement and use those if
you will mouthpieces to suggest that
African Americans should not vote this
woman is a witch you know he tried to
pretend like an angel what she's I knew
who they created if you will Amin a
social media mean under the banner of
African Americans for Hillary Clinton as
though it was coming from a group of
African Americans who supported Hillary
Clinton had her photo on it what it said
is avoid the lines vote from home text
to this number of course there was no
way to vote from home or to vote via
text now people would say well who would
be so gullible consider an 18 19 21 year
old person who's grown up in the social
media world
who all of a sudden sees something
coming quote-unquote from the campaign
suggesting that they could vote from
home and that all came from Russia from
an operation called of the internet
research agency in st. Petersburg with
what US officials say was surprising
sophistication in this deception
according to the Pew Research Center
turnout among African American voters
was down substantially in the 2016
election from 66 percent of eligible
voters to 60 percent of eligible voters
a decrease of 765,000 nationwide we had
such a close election that if the
Russians succeeded in simply fooling
some of the people some of the time in
only some of the states they could have
affected this election I wonder who in
the United States may have been
cooperating with them or assisting them
or aiding them or abetting them I can't
answer that question what answer comes
from what happened on the top floor of
this building in New York City at a
private cigar club where according to
the Muller report it was here that Trump
campaign Chairman Paul Manafort quote
brief calleb Nick identified by the FBI
as a Russian operative on the state of
the Trump campaign and mana forts plan
to win the election that briefing
encompassed the campaign's messaging and
its internal polling data here is former
Special Counsel Muller confirmed all of
that and more in his congressional
testimony this week months before that
meeting mana Ford had caused internal
data to be shared with kulhanek and the
sharing continued for some period of
time after their August meeting isn't
that correct accurate it also included a
discussion of battleground states which
men are identified as Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and Minnesota isn't that
correct that's great who knows what was
going on with the president but at least
at the the metaphor level I think
there's very strong evidence if not yet
a smoking gun that some kinds of core
could have been taking place congressman
Jamie Raskin is a Democrat from Maryland
who serves on the House Judiciary
Committee but if it makes sense to you
the people at the IRA the internet
research agency in st. Petersburg Russia
would figure out to go after black votes
in Wisconsin and Pennsylvania well we
don't know whether or not it was just a
coincidence so we know from the Muller
report that there was a sweeping and
systematic campaign by the Russians to
undermine and subvert our presidential
election in order to throw it Donald
Trump but now we have reported that the
Russians were deliberately trying to
suppress African American women from
turning out in Pennsylvania in Wisconsin
and other places and it looks like that
strategy was parallel to a Republican
strategy and joining us now from
Washington to talk about all this is
Jill wine banks a former member of the
Watergate special prosecutors team and a
former executive director of the
American Bar Association thank you for
being here let me ask you Jill wine
banks do you believe in coincidences I'm
not believer in coincidences or
conspiracy theories of course it's
certainly obvious that voters who needed
to be suppressed were African American
women but it is not a coincidence that
that's the exact information and polling
data that Manafort turned over to the
Russians and probably for financial gain
he was using his knowledge to try to get
out of some debts to oligarchy in Russia
well do you think Robert Moeller did
enough to investigate this aspect it
seems to have these these parallel
political campaigns one from st.
Petersburg Russia one from the Trump
campaign I think he established the
Russian hacking and the social media
segment but he did not follow the money
which you know going back to Watergate
following the money is exactly the way
to find things and in this case there's
a lot of financial motives for the
cooperation with Russia Donald Trump
wanted to make millions hundreds of made
from the
out and so he and the same thing is true
for Manfred who owed a great debt in
Russia and he used this power that he
had knowledge that he had to try to win
over some of the oligarchs to relieve
his debt Jill we have a question for you
from the control room from our executive
producer Jill you're a former prosecutor
why couldn't Muller do more on this why
was it beyond his purview with all our
intelligence agencies couldn't they
investigate further treatment
announcement and that said that he was
to investigate whether or not the
Russians had hacked and interfered in
our election in any way and whether
anyone the Trump team was involved in
that action which is not the same thing
as whether or not they had shared
polling data I guess I think it's a
logical extension and that if I were
making the decision as Robert Muller as
to whether or not I had jurisdiction I
would have erred on the side of
inclusiveness and I would have probably
investigated further now there is
clearly future cases still pending and
so the question is whether this is one
of the ones that he did not resolve but
he did not close and that it's one of
the ones he can't talk about because
it's still pending
so you think more might be coming very
quickly Jill I don't know if it'd be
quick but I think more coming for sure
Jill Juan banks thank you so much for
being our program tonight very much
appreciate it